You could you could talk about us everything, but but Krishna, right?
Sofia will be.
Yeah.
I think I have.
No.
Uh, no, wealth.
What are you planning for this weekend?
I have to work a little bit, but I'm having money off spend time with the family.
Yeah, nice.
Yeah.
Hey, Sofia.
Hello, how are you?
Hey, Sophia. Good, good. You tell us.
How are you?
You look busy.
Me too.
Yes, I was doing the credit, so I have to finish before I forget.
Before you could tell that you are busy, I read it on you said you are busy.
Yes.
So, what are your plans for this weekend?
We are renewing the bathroom. So let's see how it ends. It's the first time that we are going to do something like that. So let's see.
The.
I.
Reid.
Keeping you tied up for not only for the weekend, probably for a few more days.
Yes.
Yeah.
Kip.
Yep, are you having your lunch right now?
No, not yet.
Okay.
Right, so let's quickly start with our agenda. We'll make it quick, starting with Sally's performance. Sophia, how she had been in the past week.
Good, no issues. We're still, well, she's still learning about the billing questions because always is some new scenario that she needs to practice on. I'm working on trying to
show her all the process that we are involved in part of the process. So she's able now to understand what to go to where and to who to ask. So we're working on that. It's kind of busy to try to understand all of the all of this process.
Right.
so she can apply and assign the tickets to someone.
Reid.
And do you see the way she had been working on the things and working on the payments side also? Do you have you noticed any improvement with Celli on that front?
Payment application is going well, no issues. We are still working on she to have more confidence when she applied a payment. Sometimes she's like, do I have to apply or not? So we're working on that. But overall, it's good.
Thank you so much, Sophia, for sharing the feedback. And we are working with Sally in the backend to ensure that she meets the expectations. And upon Krishna's return on Tuesday, Tammy, we will continue with our targeted focus that we agreed on.
MMM.
Kip.
So just to reiterate, Monday is an off for Sally and Krishna both. And yeah, so they would resume work on Tuesday. I hope Sally is not required to put anything in her calendar in Management.
Vishal, yeah.
No, we are all off, so no.
No.
Okay, correct. So this will take care of. And Sophia, did you receive the CSAT survey for Sally?
Yes, I didn't reply, I think. I didn't reply. No, I didn't reply. I will do it today.
That says monthly feedback survey.
Yeah, I would appreciate. Please do that. And for Krishna, Tammy, I guess that survey was sent out to Ray. Sir, could you please re-trigger the survey and send it to Tammy? I have added Tammy your name for the future CSAL surveys of Krishna. However, this month, Sarbjeet will
Okay, okay.
reaching in a survey and it will be sent out to you. Within the next 10 minutes you will receive the CSET.
Okay.
Key.
Before I jump into the presentation deck, anything else of you want to share?
No, no, everything has been smooth and we're working fine with Sally.
Great, I'll share my screen.
Please let me know if you are able to see it.
Yes.
Thank you. So this is our weekly business review starting April 30th till May 6th. Our agenda attempts will remain the same. We have check-in. Next, we have highlights of the account, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of the customer, way forward, and then recap. We have discussed this already, so things are going good.
This is the highlights that we discussed in the previous Connect, where Krishna supported critical operations during the QuickBooks outreach that we spoke about, transition and process alignment underway, where Krishna is adapting to a revised AP payment process following his exit. We also noticed
Improvement with Sally's performance, and it was agreed that, you know, Tanim would be the recipient of the CCEL surveys for Krishna going forward, so yeah.
No.
These are the action tracker points. So the first one is something that has been there for quite some time where we were expecting to get the 36 to 90 days plan for Sally and Krishna. The scorecard KPIs, this is, these were finalized. We had.
brief discussion with Ray on this one. And the scorings that we requested Ray to share, however, since he's no longer with MSP Corp. So in the next screen, as we see, these were the discussed and agreed KPIs for Sally and Krishna.
And I have a separate slide where we have scoring for both individuals. So I'm dependent on Sophia, you and Tammy for perspective scoring of Sally and Krishna. If you could take out some time after this call.
and share these numbers for both of them so that we can read them internally and see where they are standing in terms of their deliverables.
Okay.
Okay, so yeah, this is something that I look forward to.
Moving on to performance analysis. So today we have only performance for Sally because Krishna was out the entire week. For Sally, she worked on 90 tickets. She closed 90 tickets during this period. And Bellum, she also completed 102 service board updates.
During this time, she maintained consistent daily productivity plus all working days while handling a mix of service port tickets.
And on the peak day, she closed 42 QuickBook payment applications that was on May 8th.
May, may, that is last last week.
Yes.
It should be more.
On the basis of the calculation, so we have 3 emails and 21 service board updates as well, along with the 42 QuickBook payment applications.
I.
Yes, I don't think that that amount is accurate, but I'm sure that she did more than that.
The payment application.
On 8th, right?
Yes, just let me double check. Just give me a second.
In the interim, uh, Tammy, Sophie, I have sent you both the surveys for Camilla and Sally, so we can check that out.
Sunidhi.
For me, it should be higher than number.
Okay, I'll verify it once again. So yeah, I'll take care of this piece. And in terms of value add, she processed 33 good book bank transactions and 37 non-ticket credit payments, completed 6 check payments and sent 9 emails during the period to support follow-up and communication.
Yes.
Oh yes, you see the number? 33 QuickBooks bank transactions and 37 credit card payments. So it's more. So it's 70.
70, okay.
Is not 42, you see?
Yep, yep.
Yep.
Thank you for the clarity, Dio.
So I think this is how we have segregated it, but I got you what you are saying.
Mhm.
Okay, so this is what we have for a performance standpoint.
Way forward, so we have a gradual increase in vendor board tickets. This is for Krishna, clear productivity benchmark to track and close the speed gap. So this is where we are dependent on you to get the numbers and then great use of structured notes, pay books, and enforce adherence to define workflow. So this is already been cascaded to.
Both individuals and they are working accordingly.
It's our team GPS piece and that is it.
Any other questions, Sophia, Tanim, you have?
Kip.
No, no, Kobe.
No on my side.
Okay, so Sarbjeet has re-triggered the C-side Service, so would appreciate your feedback there. And yeah, I guess this is all I have for my site. Sarbjeet, anything you want to add?
No, I'm all good. I'm glad that things are moving in the right direction. Rest, if there is anything at all, though we have these weekly call schedule. However, we guys are just a text away. So feel free to reach out to us. I mean, just a quick heads up. I'll also be sending out the survey for Krishna for the month of March as well, because it was pending.
Yeah.
So you will get 2 surveys there.
Okay.
Rest, thank you so much once again, Tammy, Sophia, for taking time out. You guys have a great weekend. We'll be in touch.
You too. Enjoy the three days off. Bye.
Thank you so much. Yep. Sure. Bye-bye.
Okay, thank you. Goodbye.
Thank you, bye.